Katrina: 然后还要干什么
Katrina: So, what else do we need to do?
Shure: 然后烧炭就可以起锅
Shure: Then we can start cooking once the charcoal is burning.
Katrina: 烧炭
Katrina: Burning charcoal?
Shure: 开始一会我不知道
Shure: I don't know yet.
Shure: 这个咸蛋我有点掌握不好
Shure: I can't quite handle this salted egg.
Shure: 然后一会如果淡了
Shure: If it's too light,
Shure: 就直接就是巨大的面团啊
Shure: it'll just be a massive dough.
Jake:这是什么肉啊
Jake: What kind of meat is this?
Jake:这都牛肉和鸡肉
Jake: It's all beef and chicken.
Shure: 这全是牛肉
Shure: It's all beef.
Shure: 然后这是鸡肉和排骨
Shure: And this is chicken and ribs.
Jake:哟看起来很厉害
Jake: Wow, looks impressive.
Shure: 绝绝对香
Shure: Absolutely delicious.
Shure: 跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 一般不来长春都尝不到这手艺的
Shure: Normally, you can't taste this craft outside of Changchun.
Alice:酸啊
Alice: So sour.
Shure: 今儿是偷偷漏抖都给你们了
Shure: Today, I'm secretly revealing it all for you.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 是烤的话是要在外面烤吗
Lucia: If it's grilled, should it be grilled outside?
Shure: 这比我女朋友都早
Shure: This is even earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:对那边有个好家
Jake: Yes, there's a good place over there.
Shure: 迟了两周
Shure: Two weeks late.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Jake:啊早谁谁早吃那两周啊
Jake: Ah, who ate those two weeks earlier?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 比我女朋友
Shure: Earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:他还没吃
Jake: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 那我们周日是还要弄这些是吗
Shure: So, we still need to do these on Sunday?
Jake:对周日还要弄
Jake: Yes, we still need to do it on Sunday.
Shure: 啊那应该也能吃
Shure: Ah, then we should be able to eat it too.
Alice:周日不是不吃饭吗
Alice: Aren't we not supposed to eat on Sundays?
Alice:就是加冰
Alice: Just add ice.
Jake:这烤烤一点
Jake: Just roast it a bit.
Katrina: 好一点
Katrina: A bit better.
Alice:哦提前搞一点
Alice: Oh, do it a bit earlier.
Katrina: 好一
Katrina: Okay, got it.
Shure: 意思一下懂了吧
Shure: You get it now, right?
Jake:你的意思一下
Jake: Do you get it?
Jake:或者剩一点给他哈哈哈
Jake: Or leave some for him, hahaha.
Lucia: 这外头除了那圈墙
Lucia: Besides that outer wall...
Alice:啊剩一点
Alice: Ah, leave some.
Alice:哈哈哈真嘟假嘟
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Lucia: 外头是不除了那圈墙灯没有别的灯了
Lucia: Outside, there are no other lights besides the wall lights.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:就是这5个灯
Jake: Just these five lights.
Jake:我我可以去打光
Jake: I can light it up.
Jake:就是你要什么灯吗
Jake: Do you need any specific light?
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh, no, no.
Lucia: 不是我是说如果要在外面烤的话
Lucia: I mean, if we're grilling outside...
Lucia: 外面其实还有点黑
Lucia: It's actually a bit dark outside.
Jake:啊对没关系
Jake: Ah, it's okay.
Alice:火一点起来应该好一点吧
Alice: If the fire is up, it should be better, right?
Jake:这氛围到位了
Jake: The ambiance is perfect.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 但是只有那个就是炉子那里会亮一点
Lucia: But only the stove area will be brighter.
Lucia: 咱们吃饭的桌子还挺黑的啊
Lucia: The table we're eating at is still quite dark.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不过有那个那个影棚灯
Lucia: But there's that studio light.
Alice:先找点纸盒点火吧
Alice: Let's find some paper to light the fire.
Alice:还是有火枪啥的
Alice: Or do we have a torch or something?
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Eat the garlic with it.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: The meat won't taste as good without the garlic.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: Then let's open it.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: Yeah, we can eat it, it's good.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's the honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't need it? It's okay.
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what should we do?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want some garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master eats garlic raw.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Yeah, and wash the lettuce.
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 生吃大蒜
Lucia: Eating raw garlic.
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce.
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: You've never tried it, right?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: Try it and you'll know.
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, especially with meat.
Tasha: 我知道了但
Tasha: I know, but...
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How to wash it?
Shure: 生生菜就是洗洗菜
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty tasty.
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But it leaves a garlic taste afterward.
Shure: 咋洗他咋洗知道不
Shure: Do you know how to wash it?
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Get a basin and wash it.
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: Then wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: That's why it's rare.
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Jake: What are we doing?
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce.
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: Only the lettuce isn't washed yet.
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: The potatoes...
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed.
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat potatoes, peel them.
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice them.
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Okay, can you please move this?
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do we have a basin?
Jake:没有吧
Jake: No, I don't think so.
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this? Why does it look like this?
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Does anyone want plain yogurt?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's pretty sour.
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Okay, then three of them.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Plain yogurt without sugar is good.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Yep, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Alright, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No worries, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Is there anyone else? Anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can also add white sugar.
Tasha: 其实还有人吗
Tasha: Actually, is there anyone else?
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else?
Jake:好
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, are you plain yogurt?
Jake:我给你清掉这个东西
Jake: I'll clear this thing for you.
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then it's the three of us.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Alright, I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗完眉那个玩意
Lucia: Just finished washing that thing for my eyebrows.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这也没放油
Shure: There's no oil added here.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Jake:发生什么事
Jake: What happened?
Shure: 是吧是没放油吧再倒点
Shure: Right, there's no oil added, pour some more.
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it's not working, right?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll rinse my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It's okay without oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just grabbed the bag of oysters.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, it's not okay.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: You need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: Don't you brush it when you grill it?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No brushing.
Shure: 直接烤
Shure: Just grill it directly.
Alice:不刷呦
Alice: No brushing, huh.
Jake:丢我嫌丢
Jake: I'm annoyed, throw it away.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 应该没有你什么不能看的吧
Shure: There shouldn't be anything you can't see, right?
Shure: 闭着眼睛进去吧
Shure: Just go in with your eyes closed.
Shure: 哈哈哈有
Shure: Haha, there is.
Shure: 密码吗有
Shure: Is there a password?
Jake:钢丝球是我瞎还是不在这
Jake: Am I blind or is the steel wool not here?
Lucia: 是好像是不在这
Lucia: It seems like it's not here.
Jake:是我是是不在这OK
Jake: Yeah, I'm not here. OK.
Jake:总觉得我看到了又没看到
Jake: I always feel like I see it and don't see it.
Lucia: 你可能是看到了那个就是下水的那个
Lucia: Maybe you saw the one that goes underwater.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, yeah.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh, wow.
Jake:我操哎呀
Jake: Damn, oh man.
Jake:这东西怎么这
Jake: How does this thing...
Jake:能擦干净吗这
Jake: Can it be cleaned?
Tasha: 不能就算了
Tasha: If it can't, then forget it.
Tasha: 火吧
Tasha: Fire, maybe?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: When we eat later, we need to use a spoon.
Lucia: 啊let me think
Lucia: Ah, let me think.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we still have any disposable utensils?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: Disposable, those disposable utensils.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because it seems like we don't have many spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And we need to scoop this.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I used chopsticks, let me get one for you.
Jake:哦一次性勺啊
Jake: Oh, disposable spoons, huh?
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We need to use a spoon when we eat.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: How about we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order some takeout.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, haha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: The takeout comes with these items.
Shure: 是不是还能碰上啊
Shure: Can we still get them?
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me pick one for you.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Is there a choice?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: This one on the left.
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Aren't they the same?
Tasha: 对啊他写上
Tasha: Yeah, it says so.
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what's to choose?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: They're almost the same, pick any.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where do you want me to put this?
Jake:给我放
Jake: Give it to me.
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: It's okay, don't wipe it anymore. It won't come off.
Tasha: 要把水沾到这个
Tasha: You need to get the water on this.
Tasha: 沾到
Tasha: Get it on.
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is shaped like a spoon.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing it?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: Yes, now you need to dry it.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Exactly, just...
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe it until you see...
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: No oil, no water.
Tasha: 啊这个明显还有水
Tasha: Ah, there's still clearly water.
Tasha: 你要拿新的纸再擦一下
Tasha: You need to use a new paper to wipe it again.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 你尝一口吗
Tasha: Do you want to taste it?
Tasha: 嗯不尝
Tasha: Hmm, no tasting.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Come, borrow some scissors to open the charcoal.
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of paper is sealed here, it's specifically for wiping it.
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, I didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: No need to wipe the bottom, just the inside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: I love wiping, so I'll keep wiping.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Can someone help me light the charcoal?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll do it right after I finish stirring this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Hehehe, sorry.
Jake:7秒的记忆
Jake: 7 seconds memory.
Tasha: 人不如鱼系列
Tasha: People are not as good as fish series.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's it?
Jake:锃光瓦亮是不
Jake: Shiny and bright, isn't it?
Katrina: YOLO目标检测模型
Katrina: YOLO object detection model.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where are the eggs?
Tasha: 拿3个鸡蛋
Tasha: Get three eggs.
Lucia: 我来我离得近
Lucia: I'll get them, I'm closer.
Tasha: 好那你来打吧
Tasha: Okay, then you do it.
Lucia: 我害怕我会像那天那样打吗
Lucia: I'm afraid I'll mess up like last time.
Lucia: 你你来打吧要不
Lucia: Maybe you should do it instead.
Alice:干的
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 哦因为你戴着那个手套
Lucia: Oh, because you're wearing those gloves.
Lucia: 但是我怕我不会打
Lucia: But I'm afraid I won't do it right.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 就那天不是打错过一次
Lucia: Remember how I messed up last time?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Tasha: 打这个碗里
Tasha: Crack it into this bowl.
Jake:好人类早期打蛋行为
Jake: Early human egg-cracking behavior.
Tasha: 不要碰到水
Tasha: Don't get any water in it.
Tasha: 打滴滴滴滴
Tasha: Crack it, drip, drip.
Tasha: 再滴再滴
Tasha: More, more.
Lucia: 就是小心蛋黄不能破
Lucia: Be careful not to break the yolk.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, impressive.
Lucia: 第一次就成功了
Lucia: Nailed it on the first try.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 要不还是你来吧
Lucia: Maybe you should do it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我我拿着一个
Lucia: Haha, I'll just hold one.
Jake:好看我的成功几个
Jake: Look at my successful tries.
Lucia: 你那个啥
Lucia: What about you?
Lucia: 这个要很小心的
Lucia: You have to be really careful with this.
Shure: 够了够了
Shure: That's enough, enough.
Jake:还行吧
Jake: Not bad, right?
Jake:感觉碰到了一下问题不大
Jake: Felt like it touched a bit, but it's fine.
Lucia: 我解决问题的方式回避问题
Lucia: My way of solving problems is to avoid them.
Jake:我来给你跟拍
Jake: I'll follow you with the camera.
Jake:没了
Jake: Done.
Jake:那要不
Jake: So, how about...
Jake:哎有有
Jake: Oh, there's...
Jake:有个球
Jake: There's a ball.
Shure: 火星不够
Shure: Not enough spark.
Shure: 有酒精吗咱们
Shure: Do we have alcohol?
Jake:呃有
Jake: Uh, yeah.
Jake:呃哎
Jake: Uh, hey...
Jake:有酒精吗
Jake: Do we have alcohol?
Jake:你问问诺亚
Jake: Ask Noah.
Jake:他不知道
Jake: He doesn't know.
Jake:他之前买了消毒用的
Jake: He bought some disinfectant before.
Shure: 没事那也行
Shure: It's okay, that'll work too.
Jake:你问问看用
Jake: Ask him if he can use it.
Shure: 只要是酒精就行
Shure: As long as it's alcohol, it's fine.
Alice:这个引碳引到啥时候去
Alice: How long will it take to ignite the charcoal?
Jake:不知道啊
Jake: No idea.
Shure: 路亚
Shure: Luya.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Alice:烧不起来
Alice: It won't catch fire.
Jake:咋整呢
Jake: What should we do?
Shure: 再再次引一次
Shure: Try lighting it again.
Shure: 有火吗主要咱没火
Shure: Do we have a flame? The main issue is we don't have a flame.
Jake:谢斌如不在是吧哈哈
Jake: Xie Binru isn't here, right? Haha.
Shure: 对昨天应该把他火顺来的
Shure: Yeah, we should've brought his flame from yesterday.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ugh.
Shure: 不是燃气灶
Shure: It's not a gas stove.
Shure: 就是我们的火
Shure: It's just our fire.
Shure: 运送火种
Shure: Transport the fire source.
Jake:给你挡着有用吗
Jake: Does it help if I block it for you?
Jake:有点用吗
Jake: Does it help a bit?
Shure: 走慢点走就行
Shure: Just walk slowly, it's fine.
Shure: 别把这窗帘撂着就行
Shure: Just don't let the curtain catch fire.
Shure: 又他妈中
Shure: Damn it.
Shure: 中到崩出了
Shure: It burned out again.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 再来我就不信了
Shure: Let's try again, I don't believe this.
Shure: 对我们可以把线
Shure: Yeah, we can use the wire.
Shure: 卧槽直接点
Shure: Whoa, just light it directly.
Shure: 直接放进去点
Shure: Just put it in and light it.
Jake:也也也对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Jake:大成功
Jake: Great success.
Jake:是大成功吗
Jake: Is it a great success?
Shure: 应该成功了点
Shure: It should have worked a bit.
Jake:应该成功
Jake: It should've worked.
Shure: 刚才那夹呢
Shure: Where's that clip?
Shure: 夹去哪了
Shure: Where did the clip go?
Shure: 这是什么助燃剂我记得
Shure: What's this fire accelerant, I remember.
Shure: 怎么着都能烧着应该
Shure: It should burn no matter what.
Jake:我也来点一点
Jake: Let me try lighting it too.
Jake:烧纸烧纸这玩意我会
Jake: Burning paper, burning paper, I can do this.
Jake:烧锅
Jake: Burning the pot.
Jake:火光四起
Jake: Flames everywhere.
Shure: 把那夹子要回来
Shure: Get those tongs back.
Shure: 应该没事
Shure: It should be fine.
Jake:着了着了火了火了
Jake: It's on fire, it's on fire!
Shure: 着了着
Shure: It's on fire.
Shure: 了着了
Jake:咋吃呢
Jake: How do we eat this?
Lucia: 嗯一般来说你得拿个勺挖着吃
Lucia: Well, usually you take a spoon and scoop it out.
Lucia: 但这个装蜂蜜的勺已经被我征用了
Lucia: But the honey spoon is already being used by me.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以在这种情况下
Jake: So, in this case...
Alice:你可以跟我一样用筷子吃
Alice: You can use chopsticks like me.
Jake:我找找看
Jake: Let me see if I can find some.
Lucia: 对所以你就可以考虑用筷子吃
Lucia: Yeah, so you might want to consider using chopsticks.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Jake:我再想想
Jake: Let me think.
Lucia: 咱们那个一次性的那个勺还还在吗
Lucia: Do we still have that disposable spoon?
Jake:我觉得在感觉是我放哪去了
Jake: I think we do. I put it somewhere.
Lucia: 为什么民宿里会没勺
Lucia: Why are there no spoons in the guesthouse?
Lucia: 总感觉有哪里怪怪的
Lucia: It feels kind of weird.
Lucia: 应该有才对
Lucia: There should be some.
Lucia: 让我看看有没有什么别的原料
Lucia: Let me see if there are any other ingredients.
Lucia: 给您做一个
Lucia: I’ll make you one.
Lucia: 充当一下
Lucia: Just improvise.
Lucia: 鉴定完毕没有
Lucia: Are you done with the evaluation?
Alice:我去
Alice: Oh my!
Tasha: 哦多了再煮一会
Tasha: Oh, let it cook a bit longer.
Alice:一会会不会熏黑呀
Alice: Won’t it get burned?
Jake:难搞不定
Jake: Hard to say.
Jake:算了
Jake: Forget it.
Jake:硬核
Jake: Hardcore.
Lucia: 啊这有这有点大
Lucia: Ah, this one’s a bit big.
Lucia: 洗一下吧
Lucia: Let’s wash it.
Lucia: 这个好没咋用过
Lucia: This one hasn’t been used much.
Jake:我我已经喝我已经喝到了
Jake: I-I already drank some.
Jake:我觉得挺好的
Jake: I think it’s fine.
Jake:就当就就硬喝就
Jake: Just drink it as it is.
Lucia: 哈哈你确定吗
Lucia: Haha, are you sure?
Lucia: 筷子也不需要来一个吗
Lucia: Don't we need chopsticks too?
Jake:不用了不用了挺好的
Jake: No, no, it's fine.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright then.
Jake:这啥呀这怎么做的呀
Jake: What is this? How do you make this?
Jake:用鸡精调的呀
Jake: Do you use chicken essence?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Yes, really.
Jake:真的真的吼吼
Jake: Really, really, haha.
Jake:我看看你的小本本
Jake: Let me see your little notebook.
Jake:红茶包红茶包
Jake: Black tea bags, black tea bags.
Jake:哪来的买的
Jake: Where did you buy them from?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought them.
Tasha: 你觉得哪来的
Tasha: Where do you think they're from?
Jake:买的
Jake: Bought them.
Shure: 卧槽好像是
Shure: Damn, seems like it.
Shure: 好像是哎
Shure: Seems like it, yeah.
Tasha: 林涵好聪明
Tasha: Lin Han is so smart.
Jake:加3T蛋黄
Jake: Add 3T egg yolks.
Tasha: 3个吧
Tasha: 3 of them.
Shure: 加大火势
Shure: Turn up the heat.
Jake:分两次筛入低筋面粉 0.5包
Jake: Sift in low-gluten flour in two batches, 0.5 packs.
Jake:茶包30克
Jake: 30 grams of tea bags.
Jake:奶茶23克
Jake: 23 grams of milk tea.
Jake:植物油护油脂哦
Jake: Use vegetable oil to protect the fats.
Jake:怎么回锅呢
Jake: How do we reheat this?
Jake:要把它蒸发掉是吗
Jake: Do we need to evaporate it?
Tasha: 嗯对就是浓缩到一定的比例
Tasha: Yes, just concentrate it to a certain ratio.
Jake:嗯咋没写
Jake: Why isn't it written?
Tasha: 咋没写
Tasha: Why isn't it written?
Jake:是哪一个呀
Jake: Which one is it?
Tasha: 这呢
Tasha: This one.
Jake:在哪呢 30克
Jake: Where is it? 30 grams.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Okay.
Jake:80毫升的牛奶给运煮到30克是吗
Jake: Boil 80 milliliters of milk down to 30 grams, right?
Tasha: 对就是要把它们浓缩掉
Tasha: Yes, just concentrate it.
Jake:那明白了
Jake: Got it.
Jake:明白
Jake:炼乳是这种东西吗
Jake: Is this what condensed milk is?
Tasha: 炼乳是什么东西
Tasha: What is condensed milk?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 就是你常吃的炼乳
Tasha: This is the condensed milk you often eat.
Tasha: 是这么炼的
Tasha: This is how it's made.
Jake:就是就是是
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Jake:炼乳啊那个
Jake: Condensed milk, that...
Jake:那种很甜的那种酱你知道吧
Jake: That very sweet kind of sauce, you know?
Tasha: 啊对就是那个
Tasha: Yeah, exactly that one.
Jake:就就就是这种就这么整烧出来的吗
Jake: So, this is how it's cooked and made?
Tasha: 就是这么烧出来的
Tasha: Yep, this is how it's made.
Tasha: 呃好可以是
Tasha: Uh, okay, sure.
Tasha: 完了又少了
Tasha: Oh no, it's less again.
Jake:那咋办
Jake: What should we do?
Tasha: 少了没有办法
Tasha: If it's less, there's nothing we can do.
Tasha: 味道浓一些
Tasha: The flavor will be stronger.
Jake:你上回说的你要搞
Jake: You mentioned last time that you wanted to...
Jake:几个这种彩票款
Jake: Make some of those lottery tickets.
Jake:你不是说想搞几个彩票款
Jake: Didn't you say you wanted to make some lottery tickets?
Jake:彩票款吗
Jake: Lottery tickets?
Jake:看谁能吃到
Jake: Let's see who can eat them.
Tasha: 算了呃那个打蛋器呃盆
Tasha: Forget it, uh, the egg beater, uh, the bowl.
Tasha: 对就是那个盆啊
Tasha: Yeah, that bowl.
Lucia: 呃上次用的那个
Lucia: Uh, the one we used last time.
Tasha: 就是你刚冷冻起来的那个
Tasha: The one you just froze.
Shure: 应该
Shure: Probably.
Lucia: 哦get it
Lucia: Oh, got it.
Tasha: 哎还有一个呢
Tasha: Hey, there's another one.
Alice:没反应呢
Alice: No response.
Katrina: 明天就跳跳舞是吧
Katrina: So, we're dancing tomorrow, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 然后明天要压花了
Katrina: And we need to press flowers tomorrow.
Katrina: 要不然来不及
Katrina: Otherwise, we won't have enough time.
Jake:压压花跳跳舞划划水
Jake: Press flowers, dance, and paddle.
Katrina: 对对对明天买
Katrina: Yes, yes, and buy...
Tasha: 少了一个这个
Tasha: We're missing one of these.
Katrina: 明天买下美文纸和旺仔牛
Katrina: Tomorrow, we need to buy some nice paper and Wong Lo Kat milk.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:做做早饭
Jake: And make breakfast.
Lucia: 哎奇怪我找找看
Lucia: Hmm, weird, let me check.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯有没有可能
Lucia: Hmm, is it possible...
Shure: 一根一根烧
Shure: Burn them one by one.
Katrina: 几天我想想
Katrina: How many days, let me think.
Jake:等快递整整理整理
Jake: Wait for the packages, then organize them.
Katrina: 明天是星期五了
Katrina: Tomorrow is Friday.
Lucia: 在在在在楼上呢
Lucia: Upstairs, upstairs.
Jake:明天星期五了
Jake: Tomorrow is Friday.
Jake:星期六整理整理拿到了
Jake: We can organize it on Saturday when it arrives.
Lucia: 这个不是吧
Lucia: This isn't it, right?
Katrina: 那今天晚上就
Katrina: Then tonight...
Katrina: 明天必须压了
Katrina: We must compress it by tomorrow.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 那我等会压一下
Katrina: Then I'll compress it later.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 楼家要是没有我就再上楼看一下
Lucia: If it's not downstairs, I'll check upstairs again.
Katrina: 时间过得可真快
Katrina: Time really flies.
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯啊好的
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Jake:划划水就划完了
Jake: Just paddling through the time.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Shure: 我们有特别特别高浓度的酒精吗
Shure: Do we have any really high concentration alcohol?
Jake:特别
Jake: Really?
Jake:特别高的
Jake: Really high?
Jake:什么卧槽
Jake: What the heck?
Shure: 浓度的酒精
Shure: High concentration alcohol.
Jake:多高啊要干啥
Jake: How high? What's it for?
Shure: 75那种
Shure: Like 75%.
Lucia: 助燃吧
Lucia: For burning, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:烧不起来是吧
Jake: It won't burn, right?
Jake:喝完了还行
Jake: If you finish it, it might.
Lucia: 还挺干净
Lucia: It's pretty clean.
Lucia: 来我帮你
Lucia: Let me help you.
Jake:还行
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 我我刚好帮你洗了
Lucia: I just washed it for you.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Lucia: 因为我这个也要洗
Lucia: I need to wash this too.
Jake:那我看看火去
Jake: I'll go check the fire.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 还是说他一直在这呢
Shure: Or has he been here all along?
Alice:没他就在这上边呢
Alice: No, he's just up there.
Jake:刷不完吗
Jake: Can't finish it?
Jake:烧烧 不起来吗
Jake: Burn it, won't catch fire?
Alice:这探看起来也就受了点皮外伤
Alice: This probe looks like it only has some surface scratches.
Shure: 确实没浇透
Shure: Yeah, it's not soaked enough.
Jake:哦要大酒精
Jake: Oh, we need a lot of alcohol.
Jake:那给你买一个呗
Jake: Then I'll buy one for you.
Jake:让他4020分钟再到
Jake: Have it delivered in 40 minutes.
Jake:40分钟再到
Jake: 40 minutes delivery time.
Shure: 就最快最快的酒精
Shure: The fastest alcohol.
Shure: 你就搜酒精
Shure: Just search for alcohol.
Shure: 然后最好20分钟就能到那种
Shure: Preferably one that can be delivered in 20 minutes.
Jake:好行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake:我给你搜一个美团
Jake: I'll search on Meituan.
Alice:喷点油行吗
Alice: How about spraying some oil?
Shure: 对美团
Shure: Yes, Meituan.
Shure: 油够呛真够呛
Shure: Oil might not work, really might not.
Tasha: 加75克糖
Tasha: Add 75 grams of sugar.
Shure: 或者买药那块
Shure: Or buy from the pharmacy.
Shure: 最快的应该
Shure: That's probably the fastest.
Shure: 综合排序
Shure: Sort by comprehensive.
Shure: 速度优先
Shure: Prioritize speed.
Shure: 卧槽 30是最快
Shure: Whoa, 30 minutes is the fastest.
Shure: 行先整一瓶吧
Shure: Okay, let's get one bottle first.
Jake:看30分钟
Jake: Check, 30 minutes.
Jake:是他先到还是你先着是吧
Jake: Let's see if it arrives first or you catch fire first.
Shure: 先他先
Shure: It'll arrive first.
Shure: 着还是他先到吧
Shure: It'll definitely arrive first.
Tasha: 是按一下清零
Tasha: Press once to reset.
Shure: 咱们最起码得吃上啊是吧
Shure: We should at least be able to eat, right?
Jake:其实还行吧
Jake: Actually, it's okay.
Jake:他说8:50就到了
Jake: He said he'll be here by 8:50.
Alice:我刚才是应该是
Alice: I was just...
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: It was 35 just now.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Jake:谢文竹咱吃的到
Jake: Thanks, Wen Zhu, we can eat.
Shure: 心竹过来今晚上
Jake:他说他过
Jake: He said he's coming.
Shure: 放放这边
Shure: Put it here.
Jake:我也要玩啊
Jake: I want to play too.
Jake:打发是吧
Jake: To kill time, right?
Tasha: 好你来
Tasha: Alright, your turn.
Jake:好你从哪找这样的
Jake: How did you find this?
Jake:另一个啊
Jake: The other one?
Jake:另一个那个
Jake: The other one, that one.
Jake:哎少在这小的
Jake: Hey, don't stay here, it's small.
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: Guess.
Lucia: 29.9
Jake:凑30是吗
Jake: Round it up to 30?
Tasha: 40啊
Tasha: 40!
Lucia: 40差不多
Lucia: 40, close enough.
Tasha: 好差不多来
Tasha: Alright, close enough, let's go.
Lucia: 外面那点不管他
Lucia: Don't worry about that part outside.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:这么多数字我用几
Jake: With so many numbers, which one do I use?
Tasha: 拉到最大就行哎呦
Tasha: Just pull it to the max, oh dear.
Jake:哈哈哈你不是说拉到最大就行
Jake: Hahaha, didn't you say just pull it to the max?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你猜
Lucia: Hahaha, guess.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 好好来吧
Tasha: Alright, alright, let's go.
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Lucia: 你猜我那天裤子上奶油是怎么奔上的
Lucia: Guess how the cream got on my pants that day.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake:有点突然
Jake: That was sudden.
Tasha: 雨露均沾一下
Tasha: Share the benefits a bit.
Jake:好哎好玩
Jake: Alright, this is fun.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:是这么回事吧
Jake: Is that how it is?
Tasha: 停了加最后一次糖吧
Tasha: Stop, add the sugar one last time.
Lucia: 我不知道要问威威
Lucia: I don't know, ask Weiwei.
Tasha: 加最后一次糖
Tasha: Add the sugar one last time.
Lucia: 谁
Lucia: Who?
Tasha: 停停加最后一次糖
Tasha: Stop, stop, add the sugar one last time.
Tasha: 你看呃要
Tasha: Look, uh, we need...
Tasha: 嗯嗯行没事
Tasha: Mm, okay, no problem.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 叫
Tasha: Call.
Lucia: 这个应该我有点不敢靠近你哈哈哈
Lucia: I feel a bit scared to get close to you, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 这个应该没用了
Lucia: This should be useless now.
Lucia: 酸奶都吃完了
Lucia: The yogurt is all gone.
Jake:他为什么能打起来啊
Jake: Why was he able to fight?
Tasha: 他他把空气给抽出去了
Tasha: He pumped out the air.
Tasha: 然后他就会膨胀
Tasha: And then it expanded.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK
Tasha: 好停一下
Tasha: Okay, stop for a bit.
Tasha: 嗯你看停到什么样的程度
Tasha: Hmm, see how far it can stop.
Tasha: 就你你这样子拉他他就立起来了就行
Tasha: Just pull it like this and it will stand up, that's fine.
Tasha: 东西有点太多了哦哎
Tasha: There’s a bit too much stuff. Oh, hey.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 不要再打了
Tasha: Don’t hit it anymore.
Tasha: 好了好了下场
Tasha: Alright, alright, next round.
Jake:我不用打了
Jake: I don’t need to hit it anymore.
Jake:下场下场就拿走洗掉
Jake: Next round, next round, just take it away and wash it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Tasha: 对把它拔下来洗了就行
Tasha: Yeah, just take it off and wash it.
Jake:对好的
Jake: Yeah, alright.
Tasha: 有点打的过了
Tasha: It's a bit overbeaten.
Jake:这个是挺
Jake: This is quite...
Jake:什么什么叫打过啊
Jake: What do you mean by overbeaten?
Jake:这还能打过呢
Jake: Can it really be overbeaten?
Jake:太硬了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake:哦没关系
Jake: Oh, no worries.
Tasha: 加85克这个这个嗯
Tasha: Add 85 grams of this, this, um...
Jake:排练一下
Jake: Let's rehearse.
Jake:最后一天我好好打
Jake: I'll do it well on the last day.
Lucia: 85克呃这个这是什么呀
Lucia: 85 grams of, uh, what is this?
Tasha: 你可以先倒40克
Tasha: You can pour 40 grams first.
Lucia: 低筋粉好的
Lucia: Low-gluten flour, got it.
Tasha: 然后再加45克
Tasha: Then add 45 grams more.
Tasha: 但感觉这个是不是有点小
Tasha: But doesn't this seem a bit small?
Lucia: 可能有点
Lucia: Maybe a little.
Tasha: 我感觉这个
Tasha: I think this...
Lucia: 这个这
Lucia: This, this...
Tasha: 这个小碗倒30克可能就差不多
Tasha: This small bowl, maybe 30 grams is enough.
Tasha: 好那就那就30克吧
Tasha: Alright, then 30 grams it is.
Tasha: 那加3次要加85克
Tasha: So we need to add 85 grams in three times.
Lucia: 行稍等二九点啊
Lucia: Okay, wait a moment, it's 29 points.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: A little more.
Lucia: 耶刚好
Lucia: Yay, just right.
Tasha: 茶包
Tasha: Teabag.
Katrina: 你妈这能看出来
Katrina: Your mom can see this.
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Katrina: 你刚那平板的充电宝呢
Katrina: Where's the power bank for your tablet?
Shure: 我跟我妈
Shure: My mom and I...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:哦哦哦你妈给你指导的是吧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, your mom's guiding you, right?
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Lucia: How much for the second playback, 20 or 25?
Shure: 对远程指导
Shure: Yeah, remote guidance.
Jake:哦可以可以
Jake: Oh, okay, okay.
Jake:为了不断为了不止于修硕
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: Total is 85, earlier was 30.
Shure: 那个呢
Shure: What about that?
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: So, 50 more to go.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: Your fire...
Shure: 油肯定不能放吧
Shure: Probably can't add oil.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:助然嘛
Jake: Fine then.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then?
Katrina: 你妈说烧烤粉放少了
Katrina: Your mom said the barbecue powder is too little.
Alice:什么这么呛
Alice: Why is it so choking?
Shure: 他说好看着
Shure: He said to keep an eye on it.
Shure: 因为正常好像他说是要放酱油的
Shure: Because normally he says you need to add soy sauce.
Shure: 但是我忘记有这个
Shure: But I forgot about that.
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, and then rely on the soy sauce for flavor.
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: So, can it still be saved?
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can we save it?
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: One part is for color.
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: Another part is for the salty taste.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: So, just add a bit of this.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Add some, alright.
Lucia: 24.9
Lucia: 24.9.
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Come on, add the soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: No soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So, I didn't buy it, you know?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: Then what to do? Add some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: Just missing this.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: I added some BBQ seasoning, it should be fine.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: A low-budget version is not a big deal.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh, man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: I've restored 80% already.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Is it ready?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: 24.8, is that okay? Not bad, right?
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And also...
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, the low-gluten flour is used up pretty fast, huh? Haha.
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to check it later.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'll go check the fire outside.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: Alright, the fire is completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the butler.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a single spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Can the butler help us get some alcohol?
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: There should be some, ask for alcohol quickly.
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: Anyway, we need it for the last day.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Ask the butler if there's any alcohol.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 那个到哪了瞅一眼
Shure: Where is it? Let me have a look.
Shure: 点一下完成
Shure: Just press complete.
Shure: OK 9分钟39就能吃上了
Shure: OK, in 9 minutes and 39 seconds, we can eat.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: We can eat, right?
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: Does it take a long time to roast?
Lucia: 哇这个这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this...
Lucia: 好像我爸每次炒的牛肉
Lucia: It looks like the beef my dad fries every time.
Lucia: 他就会拌成这样
Lucia: He always mixes it like this.
Lucia: 非常非常像
Lucia: Very, very similar.
Tasha: 茶包哎
Tasha: Tea bags, hey.
Tasha: 我刚拿了吗
Tasha: Did I just grab them?
Lucia: 饿了哈哈哈饿了
Lucia: Hungry, haha, I'm hungry.
Alice:好想下手抓一抓
Alice: Really want to grab a handful.
Tasha: 然后加哦
Tasha: Then add it, oh.
Tasha: 植物油植物油
Tasha: Vegetable oil, vegetable oil.
Tasha: 哎哎这呢
Tasha: Hey hey, here it is.
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: This is called Earl Grey milk tea, right?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Oil, oil, hey, where's the oil?
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who put this here?
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Okay, can you stir it?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just stir it with chopsticks.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: How thoroughly should it be stirred?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Just until it's blended.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: It's okay, it'll blend more later.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, to blend these two, it might take...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe down the grill later.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: This blends easily.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: It's done.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, first deal with Newton.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how does this melt?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway, right.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: Anyway, physics has its own issues.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 生物学有关的问题都归到牛顿头上
Lucia: Anything related to biology is blamed on Newton.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 就脚就行了
Tasha: Just step on it.
Alice:擦完之后是不是还得洗
Alice: After wiping, do we need to wash it?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Tasha: 因为会打过
Tasha: Because it'll be hit again.
Tasha: 应该没有问题了
Tasha: There shouldn't be any problem.
Jake:那为什么不能用他的那个一
Jake: Then why can't we use his...
Jake:他不是有好几档吗
Jake: Doesn't he have several settings?
Tasha: 是的你真的很聪明
Tasha: Yes, you are really smart.
Tasha: 要不你来
Tasha: How about you do it?
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh dear.
Tasha: 这是切蛋糕
Tasha: This is cutting the cake.
Tasha: 的
Tasha: Of
Jake:这是切蛋糕的
Jake: This is for cutting the cake
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, yeah, that day Tasha explained how to use it
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But honestly, I didn't really get it
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, this is how you use it
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it in a bit
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Jake:我要切
Jake: I want to cut it
Tasha: 好你切
Tasha: Okay, you cut it
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright
Jake:我想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine
Jake:一点都想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine it at all
Tasha: 你能帮我扶一下
Tasha: Can you help me hold this?
Tasha: 从这开始
Tasha: Starting from here
Lucia: 这个大概搅成什么样呀
Lucia: How should this be mixed?
Tasha: 就这样就行了
Tasha: Just like this is fine
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay
Tasha: 只不过我这边还在压模具
Tasha: But I'm still pressing the mold here
Lucia: 嗯那我趁你压的时候接着搅搅
Lucia: Okay, I'll keep mixing while you press
Tasha: 压的不好看
Tasha: It's not pressed nicely
Tasha: 不过没关系
Tasha: But it's okay
Tasha: 我不想认真叠它了就这样
Tasha: I don't want to be too meticulous, just like this
Alice:我的边边呢
Alice: Where's my edge?
Tasha: 什么你来好了呀
Tasha: What? You do it then
Tasha: 然后又
Tasha: And then again
Shure: 有两块着了
Shure: Two pieces got burned
Jake:哦那就有戏啊
Jake: Oh, then there's hope
Alice:先天打工圣体这是
Alice: This is the innate worker's body
Shure: 他俩很着急
Shure: They're in a hurry
Shure: 然后我们还有一个非常重要素材就是
Shure: And then we have another very important material which is
Shure: 哦看到了看到了
Shure: Oh, I see it, I see it
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just needs baking
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: This has been preheated
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake for 40 minutes
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait, that's it, mm-hmm
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: Then whip the cream
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But we can whip the cream when it's almost done baking
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: Are we finishing on Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday.
Jake:周周一周日搞完活动周一
Jake: We'll wrap up the event on Sunday, then on Monday...
Jake:呃划划水
Jake: ...uh, we'll slack off a bit.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:复个盘拆屋子
Jake: Then we'll review and dismantle the place.
Jake:把屋子拆了
Jake: Take down everything.
Shure: 到骑手还有多久
Shure: How much longer until the rider gets here?
Shure: 是不是快到了
Shure: Is he almost here?
Jake:四分钟
Jake: Four minutes.
Shure: OK那我们一会保留一块活种
Shure: OK, then let's keep a small live patch...
Shure: 然后把剩下的全浇上
Shure: ...and water the rest.
Shure: 那什么然后拿他的这个热量把
Shure: Then use the heat from that to...
Shure: 那个酒精给引着
Shure: ...ignite the alcohol.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Shure: 这个原理
Shure: That's the principle.
Jake:很make sense
Jake: Makes sense.
Jake:太合理了
Jake: Totally reasonable.
Shure: 对道理道理
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:当代牛顿
Jake: Modern-day Newton.
Shure: 都是这个道理
Shure: It's all about principles.
Jake:当代爱因斯坦
Jake: Modern-day Einstein.
Shure: 他能不能着
Shure: Will it light?
Shure: 那他是是他的造化了
Shure: If it does, it's his luck.
Jake:还有再不能招
Jake: If it doesn't light up...
Jake:倒汽油有用吗
Jake: ...will gasoline help?
Shure: 汽油可以
Shure: Gasoline can work.
Jake:汽油可以这油不行
Jake: Gasoline can, but this oil won't.
Shure: 汽油可以
Shure: Gasoline can work.
Tasha: 现在开始哎
Tasha: Starting now.
Shure: 这个油肯定不行
Shure: This oil definitely won't work.
Shure: 你还有汽油啊
Shure: Do you have any gasoline left?
Jake:我们没有汽油但是可以
Jake: We don't have gasoline but...
Shure: 哈哈哈他有两块
Shure: Haha, he has two pieces.
Shure: 着了汽油你可以倒回家去
Shure: If it lights up, you can take it home.
Jake:但是汽油你可以到换家借
Jake: But you can borrow some gasoline from home.
Shure: 哈哈我操
Shure: Haha, oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以是烤不开是吗
Tasha: So it won't cook then?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Tasha: 点不着是吗
Tasha: Can't light it, huh?
Shure: 马上找了
Shure: Almost got it.
Shure: 酒精马上到了
Shure: The alcohol is coming.
Jake:哈哈还特地买了酒精
Jake: Haha, you even bought alcohol specially.
Shure: 你们可以出来
Shure: You guys can come out.
Shure: 就是布置布置这桌子
Shure: Just set up the table.
Shure: 马上就能吃了
Shure: We can eat soon.
Shure: 先把饼给你们画圆了
Shure: I'll first draw a circle for you on the pancake.
Shure: 然后可以布置布置桌子了
Shure: Then we can set up the table.
Shure: 准备准备吃了
Shure: Get ready to eat.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:至少就是那个几块钱
Jake: At least it costs a few bucks.
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Go outside, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a New Dollar.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: 50 cents New Dollar.
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: Can't remember.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can try.
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple happiness.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: Then you put the cake here.
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: Then move it like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Alright, you demonstrate later.
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Okay, leave it to me.
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: I'll try cutting a potato first.
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you need to do the first layer.
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: The third layer and the top layer.
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: That way you can cut it out.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:我先试试
Jake: Let me try first.
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Don't you need to add mango?
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a layer of mango filling.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: And a layer of cream filling.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, it tastes so good.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: And then there's a layer of strawberry filling, etc.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: And then a layer...
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, alright, alright.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do we do this?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Then just slice the strawberries.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: We're slicing mangoes, right?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say to use up all the mangoes?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yeah, just chop them up into pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Beans and chocolate chips filling.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So, what filling does everyone want?
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just fill it with whatever filling you like.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: Gosh, this is so blissful.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango, oh mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How should I prepare it?
Tasha: 你要怎能准备他把皮削了
Tasha: You need to peel it first.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: Then if you want big pieces, don't cut them.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add them slice by slice.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Alright, I'll go get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want mango cubes, then chop them all into cubes.
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Okay, got it, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: So perfunctory.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:好来了来了来了嘿
Jake: Alright, coming, coming, hey.
Jake:谢谢您再见
Jake: Thank you, goodbye.
Jake:哈哈哈来吧
Jake: Hahaha, come on.
Shure: 又又买了什么
Shure: What did you buy again?
Shure: 啊对咱没勺
Shure: Ah, right, we don't have a spoon.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 早说配勺的话配点酱油不就得了吗
Shure: If you said we needed spoons, we could've gotten some soy sauce too.
Shure: 不就把这个问题
Shure: Wouldn't that solve the problem?
Shure: 酱油的问题也给解决了吗哈哈哈
Shure: It would solve the soy sauce problem too, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 那个夹子去
Shure: Get that clip.
Shure: 我怕直接把这个一撒再给它浇灭了
Shure: I'm afraid if we spill it, we'll have to clean it up.
Shure: 哎那个碳夹呢
Shure: Hey, where are the carbon tongs?
Jake:当时一直没找着是吧
Jake: Couldn't find them earlier, right?
Shure: 不是我刚才找着这呢
Shure: No, I just found them here.
Shure: 直接放桌上
Shure: Just put it on the table.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:没关系留点遗憾留个20%
Jake: It's alright, let's leave a bit of imperfection, like 20%.
Shure: 这个成功
Shure: This is successful.
Shure: 实验样本放在这边
Shure: Place the experiment sample over here.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then
Shure: 浇上去
Shure: Pour it on.
Shure: 玩会尿炕啊
Shure: Playing around can get you in trouble.
Shure: 小朋友们切勿模仿
Shure: Kids, do not imitate this.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 手上整的
Shure: It's all over my hands.
Jake:为啥玩火燎炕
Jake: Why play with fire?
Jake:为为为什么呢
Jake: Why, why?
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: Cake prototype.
Jake:他给的那个出燃机是什么东西
Jake: What exactly is that fire starter he gave us?
Shure: 就是一个特别特别能烧的东西
Shure: It's something really, really flammable.
Jake:一烧就没了
Jake: It burns out instantly.
Jake:这味真大
Jake: It smells really strong.
Jake:来我给你端酒
Jake: Let me get you a drink.
Shure: 这个咱把这个整着了
Shure: Let's get this thing going.
Alice:酒精是不是送到了
Alice: Did the alcohol arrive?
Jake:到了
Jake: Yes, it did.
Shure: 送到了
Shure: It arrived.
Shure: 接着这个把这个先点着
Shure: Now let's light this up.
Tasha: 擦干就行
Tasha: Just dry it off.
Shure: 好像点不着他似的你要不
Shure: It seems like it won't light. Maybe you should...
Shure: 要不借着这个你再去
Shure: Maybe use this and go...
Shure: 那个屋里去
Shure: Go to that room.
Shure: 屋里再烧一下子
Shure: Light it in the room.
Shure: 对交给你了
Shure: Yeah, it's up to you.
Shure: 咱先等他静候他
Shure: Let's wait for it.
Jake:咱是不是打个火
Jake: Should we light a fire?
Jake:买个火机是不是也挺好的哈哈哈
Jake: Buying a lighter wouldn't be a bad idea, haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 就单核摘
Shure: Just pick it.
Shure: 单线程没有工人就是不行
Jake:单细胞生物
Jake: Single-celled organism.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 草履虫只能进行一些简单的生命活动
Shure: Paramecia can only perform some basic life activities.
Shure: 着了吗
Shure: Is it ready?
Jake:密码也只要7天就
Jake: The password only needs 7 days.
Shure: 对 3天才能记住
Shure: Yeah, it takes 3 days to remember it.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: Let me cut it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred flame is coming.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it slow.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Even slower, even slower, OK.
Shure: 稳住稳住
Shure: Steady, steady.
Shure: 给他立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Katrina: 你最擅长
Katrina: You're the best at this.
Shure: 立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Jake:哎是为什么要打奶油是吗
Jake: Hey, why do we need to whip the cream?
Katrina: 哎是来
Katrina: Hey, come here.
Lucia: 哎这个是还没洗是吧
Lucia: Hey, this hasn't been washed, right?
Shure: OK OK好好
Shure: OK, OK, good.
Tasha: 这个不用洗因为他还是放蛋黄
Tasha: This doesn't need washing because it still has egg yolk.
Lucia: 哦行
Lucia: Oh, alright.
Shure: 给他
Shure: Give it to him.
Tasha: 让你打3个蛋你怎
Tasha: I asked you to beat 3 eggs, but you...
Jake:这样好不行啊
Jake: Is this good? No, it won't work.
Lucia: 补充点能量才能打得好
Lucia: You need to replenish energy to beat well.
Jake:对对对打蛋得费劲呢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, beating eggs takes effort.
Jake:打了打了
Jake: Beat it, beat it.
Tasha: 这呢这呢
Tasha: Here, here.
Jake:对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 无菌手套不够了不戴了我洗干净
Tasha: We're out of sterile gloves, I’ll just wash my hands clean.
Alice:我刚才见了这
Alice: I just saw this...
Lucia: 幸
Lucia: Lucky...
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Alright.
Tasha: 好好好好好
Tasha: Alright, alright, alright.
Lucia: 他盖着盖子
Lucia: He's got the lid on.
Jake:嗯好谢谢
Jake: Hmm, good, thanks.
Lucia: 哇好厉害啊
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 打蛋是一门学问你学不来
Tasha: Beating eggs is an art, you can't learn it.
Lucia: 对我学不来哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, I can't learn it, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: the next
Jake:哎我觉得
Jake: Hey, I think...
Lucia: 再再来一个是吧
Lucia: Let's do another one, right?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得还有两个赞嘛
Jake: Hahaha, I think we still have two likes.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: I'll do it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 专注气氛组一万年
Lucia: Focusing on the atmosphere team forever.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my god.
Lucia: 你这个会磕太厉害了
Lucia: You're gonna hit it too hard.
Lucia: 小心哇这都没了哈哈
Lucia: Careful, wow, it's almost gone, haha.
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 天选打单人
Lucia: Chosen one playing solo.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yes, this is about gradually exploring the boundaries.
Lucia: 他刚才超级强的磕了一下竟然弄没了
Lucia: He just hit it super hard, and it disappeared.
Katrina: 我也听到了
Katrina: I heard it too.
Katrina: 我也会烂在手上
Katrina: It would break in my hands too.
Tasha: 这个这个这个放到那个冷藏yes
Tasha: This, this, this, put it in the fridge, yes.
Lucia: 对OK
Lucia: Right, okay.
Lucia: 看一眼那可能还是得放到楼上去
Lucia: Take a look, maybe we still need to put it upstairs.
Tasha: 你可以把这个没事你去吧
Tasha: You can take this, it's okay, go ahead.
Lucia: 这个这个放在哪
Lucia: Where to put this?
Lucia: 这已经擦好了
Lucia: This is already cleaned.
Tasha: 呃干的就放在这就行我觉得
Tasha: Uh, just put the dry one here, I think.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:哎真好看
Jake: Oh, it looks really nice.
Tasha: 这个擦一下这个
Tasha: Wipe this, wipe this.
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Jake:这个好
Jake: This is good.
Jake:哇起火了
Jake: Wow, it's on fire.
Jake:哇好开心
Jake: Wow, so exciting.
Jake:看一眼烤一烤
Jake: Take a look, roast it a bit.
Jake:为什么这么牛逼
Jake: Why is it so awesome?
Shure: 因为酒精牛逼
Shure: Because alcohol is awesome.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Shure: 不会
Shure: It won't.
Alice:这俩腿打架啊
Alice: These two legs are fighting.
Shure: 酒精烧完了他都没烧吧
Shure: The alcohol burned out, it didn't burn anything.
Shure: 完了完了
Shure: It's over, it's over.
Jake:完了原来是纸的
Jake: Oh no, it's actually paper.
Alice:不耐烧
Alice: Not fireproof.
Shure: 实在烧实在烧了
Shure: It's really burning, it's really burning.
Jake:纸在烧我以为碳全烧起来了
Jake: The paper is burning. I thought the charcoal was completely on fire.
Shure: 他们确实烧起来了
Shure: They're definitely on fire.
Jake:哦小烧起
Jake: Oh, it's a small fire.
Shure: 我们应该给底下垫一层纸壳
Shure: We should put a layer of cardboard underneath.
Shure: 然后纸壳一直在烧的话
Shure: And if the cardboard keeps burning,
Shure: 他就应该可以拿回去干吧
Shure: he should be able to take it back and dry it, right?
Jake:那我们这么干吧
Jake: Then let's do it that way.
Jake:我们有足够的纸
Jake: We have enough paper.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How's that?
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sounds good.
Tasha: 交给您
Tasha: I'll leave it to you.
Tasha: 您来
Tasha: You do it.